[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
could be helpful for example in Montana
at a four-way stop the guy with the
biggest moose tied to his hood has the
right-of-way in Chicago anything in your
pocket can at any time be confiscated
for use in sausage in Texas you can
marry your gun as long as it isn't a
blood relative in Bakersfield California
it's illegal to make fun of fresno
california because duh have you seen
bakersfield in new mexico it is illegal
to kill unless it's for turquoise
jewelry in beverly hills california you
can get out of a speeding ticket if your
face is melting
in Massachusetts no male resident is
allowed to be played by anyone other
than Casey Affleck in Queens New York
Angie I swear to god you got to tell me
what's in that sauce in Florida in
Florida anyone stopped without meth in
their car will be sold some meth in
Sioux City Iowa it's illegal to find
something to do in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania you may only marry a
cheesesteak in a civil ceremony in South
Dakota it's a $1,000 fine for referring
to the state as North Dakota's versatile
bottom and finally in Fayetteville
Arkansas you must refer to the Bakley
bike lane as the cup chute
[Applause]
you